it's all about the benjamins baby
these benjamins of course 100 bills
adorned with a portrait of benjamin
franklin but have you ever wondered why
it's
his face on the bill or why we put faces
of presidents
and some non-presidents on american
money well dear viewers
i will be answering that very question
as i explain the history of the people
on the money of these united states
money has been around for about as long
as the civilization has existed
before middle coins many different
things were used as money
like clay tablets beads and shells
[Music]
the first metal coins were from lydia an
ancient civilization in modern day
turkey
the usefulness durability and popularity
of these coins
caused other neighboring civilizations
like the greeks
to adopt the practice it wasn't long
before the faces of powerful people
like kings and emperors adorned these
coins
after america's founding the opinion was
that
presidents or other founding fathers
shouldn't be put on the money
we had just broken from a monarchy and
didn't want to adopt
their tradition of putting leaders on
the coins
so for the first almost 150 years
of the republic no presidents were
featured on our coinage
instead lady liberty a symbol of freedom
and democracy
was on the front of coins while the
american eagle
was on the back until finally in the
year 1909 the 100th
anniversary of abraham lincoln's birth
president teddy roosevelt
championed an initiative to put lincoln
on the penny
the design was based on a sculpture by
victor
david brenner which is why the bust of
lincoln is facing the opposite direction
from everyone else it was originally
going to be
commemorative and only last one year
but the lincoln penny proved so popular
with the public that the u.s
mint decided to keep it ever since
27 years later in 1932 the bicentennial
celebration of washington's birth
george washington got his turn to be on
a coin
this time the quarter again it was
designed to be only for a year
but was extended to this day due to its
popularity
with these two examples the floodgates
were opened in 1938
thomas jefferson the third president and
writer of the declaration of
independence was put on the nickel in
1946
after the second world war and president
frederick delano roosevelt's death
there was a grassroots campaign to get
him on a coin and the us mint was more
than happy to put him
on the dime after the assassination of
president john f kennedy in
1963 the mint wasted no time
in putting his portrait on the half
dollar which is a coin we don't see too
often
speaking of dollar coins have not been
particularly popular in the united
states
but they are made and are still in
circulation
in 1971 dwight d eisenhower was put on a
dollar coin
but it only ran until 1978. susan b
anthony was also put on a dollar coin
but the coins were somewhat unpopular
because of their confusion with quarters
so it was replaced by the current dollar
coin
which features a portrait of saku joaya
the native american woman who guided
lewis and clark on their famous
exploration
moving on to notes the first paper money
was created in the tang dynasty in china
during the 7th
century so by the time the united states
was founded
paper money had been around for
centuries but surprisingly the federal
government of the us
didn't start printing bank notes until
1861
almost 100 years after the country's
founding before that point
private banks were permitted to simply
print their own notes
so there were dozens if not hundreds of
different paper currencies in the us at
the time
as i said the us government started
printing greenbacks
named so because of the green ink used
in
1861 as a way of paying for expenses
related to the civil war at this point
though it was before any president ended
up on a coin the american people seemed
fine
with the idea of putting a president or
other political leaders on the bills
the first u.s bank notes had some of the
classics
like george washington and alexander
hamilton
but it also had some surprises like
abraham lincoln who of course we're used
to seeing
now but keep in mind he was still the
president at the time
and of course you all know salmon
portland chase
no well he was the treasury secretary
under lincoln so i guess that makes
sense
as time went on there were a great
number of people who showed up on the
bills
many presidents senators cabinet members
and so on
two noteworthy people i want to mention
were martha washington
george washington's wife and first first
lady of the united states
she to this day is the only woman to
show up on a u.s banknote
and running antelope a sioux chief of
the
hong papa indians he is the only native
american
and person of color to show up on
american paper money
man that is a bit embarrassing in 1928
the current slate of portraits on
american paper money was solidified
washington on the one jefferson on the
two
lincoln on the five hamilton on the 10
jackson on the 20 grant on the 50
and franklin on the 100. it was
confirmed in 2016 that harriet tubman
the great abolitionist and political
activist would be replacing andrew
jackson on the
20 bill becoming the first
african-american woman
and first black american period to be
featured on american paper money
the change was set to happen in 2020 but
unfortunately
it has been postponed until 2028.
at that time the 10 and 50 notes will
also have redesigns
so we will all have to wait and see
hello thanks for watching my video about
american money
please like the video if you liked it
please subscribe if you want to be
updated every time
i upload a new video and consider
sharing the video with your friends
and check out some of my other videos if
you want to learn more
bye